la distribución de las tasas de
pulsaciones en reposo de todos los
estudiantes de una escuela es
aproximadamente normal con una media de
80 pulsaciones por minuto y una
desviación estándar de 9 pulsaciones por
minuto la enfermera de la escuela va a
observar con más cuidado a los
estudiantes cuyas tasas de pulsaciones
en reposo se encuentren por arriba del
30 por ciento de los estudiantes
analizados cuál es la tasa mínima de
pulsaciones en reposo de los estudiantes
que recibirán una observación más
cuidadosa redondea al entero más cercano
si creen que pueden resolver esto por su
cuenta los invito a que lo hagan
resolvamos esto juntos nos dicen que la
distribución de pulsaciones en reposo es
aproximadamente normal por lo que
podemos usar una distribución normal y
nos dicen varias cosas de esta
distribución normal la media es de 80
pulsaciones por minuto lo escribimos y
nos dicen que la desviación estándar es
de 9 pulsaciones por minuto en esta
gráfica tenemos una desviación
por encima de la media aquí y dos
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media acá por lo que aquí tenemos 89
este valor de aquí será 98 también
tenemos desviaciones estándar por debajo
de la media que sería esta 71 y esta
otra sería 62 pero nos interesa el 30%
superior ya que son los estudiantes a
los que se observarán con más cuidado
por aquí hay un valor o un límite
digamos que está acá que si alguna
estudiante tiene este valor o uno mayor
será observado con más cuidado pues se
encontrará en el 30% superior esta área
que estoy señalando es el 30% o 0.3 lo
que podemos hacer es usar una tabla zeta
y preguntarnos para qué puntaje z
tenemos una distribución del 70 por
ciento menor a este después tomamos ese
puntaje z la media y la desviación
estándar para encontrar el valor que nos
piden en ejemplos anteriores comenzamos
con el puntaje z y después buscamos el
porcentaje pero en este caso es lo
esto vamos a buscar el porcentaje que
debe ser al menos 70 por ciento para
encontrar el puntaje z que le
corresponde nos encontramos a la derecha
de la media por lo que tendremos un
puntaje z positivo aquí comenzamos con
50% y vamos a buscar un valor cercano al
70% vamos a buscar nos vamos acercando y
este 0.7 1.019 es el puntaje z más
pequeño que es mayor que el 70% que es
el límite que nos interesa el puntaje z
que le corresponde es 0.53 vamos a
escribirlo
ahora tenemos que encontrar qué valor
nos da un puntaje z de 0.53 esto
significa 0.53 desviaciones estándar por
encima de la media para obtener el valor
tomamos nuestra media y le sumamos 0.53
que multiplicamos por la desviación
estándar que es 9 y nos da 0.53 por 9 es
igual a 4.77 y le sumamos 80 nos queda
84 puntos
7 lo escribimos nos piden redondear al
entero más cercano que es 85 pulsaciones
por minuto si tenemos más de 85
pulsaciones por minuto en reposo
entonces la enfermera de la escuela nos
va a observar con mayor cuidado por
estar dentro del 30% superior